you somehow we've never gotten the true
swaeley solo album what's what's the
status with that buddy facts not fake
it's just like
you know what I'm saying it's the whole
agenda going on so it's like
Ray Sherman that's like main focus 24a
like that's the main focus but now I
think it's like now that everything in
overdrive like this year and just like
now that I know the direction I really
just want to go my music like I always
knew I wanted to go up you just now he
just wouldn't leak the meat pick
got a little cold right now oh okay so
I'm taking a little medic I drink a lot
of water
I mean are we good all right but not yet
yeah definitely this year like and I
ain't just gonna say one solo project
just like which albums on albums you
know saying shrimp like might drop a
couple projects true shroom life shroom
life yeah we come with them back to back
tour with post Malone
solo tour
I feel like yeah because solo projects
yeah we all just
and you definitely on this album that's
like it's real interest like you're
gonna get a sample of both of us by
itself of course you it's not you know
what I'm saying people don't I'm excited
for it I don't want to give no
hints about the album it's gonna be a
good hour so it comes out April 7th
April now we're getting we're getting I
feel what you're saying he's saying
you're getting some gym Slim Jimmy hooks
like big Slim Jimmy hooks like you know
what I'm saying like on the early one
it's like boom
I might be on the majority of the hooks
like
people now they're getting to understand
Slim Jimmy even more in the boom
understanding of what he brings to the
table understand what I bring to the
table like you can hear him on the
standout songs you can hear me on some
standout songs and it's just like and
hear post Malone on a song a little
postie
might drop a little verse you know what
I'm saying ah Mike Johnson confirmed
by the end of the interview
or is that a soft confirmation it's a
soft confirmation obviously
so the confirmation wasn't gonna be a
hard one it was going to be a soft one
hey yo whoa that was a good one though
that was a good one that was fine
ladies no we got the hard proof though
for you the hard proof for the ladies
are both you guys single right now
is it is it complicated what's going on
I mean I got some big news I'm probably
gonna as soon as this interview come out
man I'm announced the big news man okay
I don't know if the world ready man for
this one
Jesus I'm about to sing some crazy
you're single and he's gonna announce
that he's I don't know I don't know I'm
single as a pringle ready to mingle but
got down you know what I'm saying right
now I'm in a serious relationship with
myself so I'm not even trying to do that
manual stimulation is what it's all
about
um
there it is guys well I appreciate y'all
April 7th the new album is out it's out
right now follow us up shrimp like full
man your life full show for Life shout
out to all the stands shout out to
shrimp like day ones yes sir boom